This isn’t just a popular metaphor, it’s
actually true.
One bad apple will absolutely quickly spoil
an entire box of apples.
The obvious way this can happen is simply
if one of the apples is infested with some
fungi or critters that reproduce and spread
throughout all the apples in a box, ruining
them as they go.
The less obvious, but perhaps even more common,
way this can happen has to do with a hydrocarbon
chemical known as ethylene.
Ethylene is a hormone produced and released
into the air by most plants, including from
the fruit of certain plants, such as apples,
bananas, pears, etc.
So what does this have to do with one “bad”
apple?
The “bad” apple is usually one that is
wounded in some way or is otherwise overripe.
As a consequence to the wound on the apple,
or if it’s just already very ripe, the apple
in question will give off significantly more
ethylene than normal.
That ethylene accelerates the ripening process
in the apples around it, which causes them
to give off more ethylene, further accelerating
the ripening process in all the apples in
the box.
In very short order, the entire box of apples
will be overripe and eventually unpalatable
for eating.
Humans have actually been using ethylene to
control ripening processes since before we
knew about the hormone.
The first known instance of this was in ancient
Egypt where they would slash figs and place
them with other fruits and vegetables in order
to accelerate the ripening process, with the
wound stimulating the production of relatively
large amounts of ethylene.
Today, ethylene is popularly used by banana
distributors to partially ripen the fruit
before the final distribution to stores.
Bananas are picked when they are quite green
and hard.
They are shipped this way to allow them to
be in transit for longer periods, as well
as reduce the chances of bruising during transport.
Once they are at the local distribution warehouses,
they are often exposed to ethylene gas in
a closed chamber for 24-48 hours to drastically
accelerate the ripening process, making them
ready for store shelves.
Even if un-wounded, bananas put off large
amounts of ethylene relative to many other
fruits.
In fact, if you’d like to speed up the ripening
of some green bananas or other fruit or vegetables,
put them in a paper bag together overnight.
The trapped ethylene will quickly ripen the
fruit, and the paper bag will still let enough
oxygen in to keep the ripening process going
smoothly.
On the same token, putting fresh bananas in
the same container as an overripe banana will
drastically accelerate the ripening process
of the fresh bananas, which is already quite
a fast process.
On the flipside, if you want to slow the ripening
of bananas, put them in the refrigerator.
Contrary to what you might think from seeing
the bananas rapidly turn to brown and then
black when placed in a refrigerator, this
drastically slows the internal ripening process
of the fruit.
The skin will look like the banana is rotten,
but the inside will stay tasty for up to about
a week.
So wait until a hand of bananas reaches the
perfect ripeness, then plop them in your fridge
to lock them in that state for about a week.
No more bothering with the tiny window of
eating opportunity normally presented by bananas
left on the kitchen counter.